>>The world is going through a financial crisis.
It is challenging.
It is difficult.
There is a lot of competition for finances.
And democracies where people have to agree
on allocating of funds, it
is a challenge to be able to dedicate money
to alleviate poverty in our
world.
I understand that challenge very well.
I also understand that the World Bank and
other institutions around the
world have done great work over the years
with the support of many
countries.
Making sure that we help the poor, make sure
that people have access to
clean water, have access to food, have access
to basic necessities that
we take for granted around the world.
And think this is an opportune time for all
of us to remember through
these challenging times that there are millions
of people out there
that need our help, need our support, and
we should all make sure that
we dedicate enough resources so that we don't
forget the poor.
We don't lose out on the investment that was
made in the years past.
It is very important, very critical for
all of us to make sure this
message goes out to everyone.
We all want to make sure that whatever little
we have to give to ensure
people's access to water, to people's access
to education, in order to
create even new consumers around the world
through economic development
is a challenge that we all feel is part of
our duty.